now the story of a young man teaching
math to the world newshour correspondent
spencer michaels reports
so this is a a quadratic equation
essentially we're trying to find the
zeros this disembodied voice is heard
every day by tens of thousands of
students struggling with math both in
the u.s and around the world
33 year old salman khan recently quit
his job as a hedge fund analyst to
devote himself to an unpaid job teaching
math on the internet
welcome to the presentation on basic
edition
i know what you're thinking
these are cancers or cancer cells the
investors and the mortgage-backed
securities
he has posted 1200 lessons on youtube
which appear on an electronic blackboard
and range in subject from basic addition
and advanced calculus to science and
finance and they are free introduction
to trigonometry is where i teach people
about the trig functions this is one of
the more popular videos this has 179 000
views and you know this is just what
what sine cosine and tangent are
khan lives in california's silicon
valley with his wife a rheumatologist in
training at stanford and their new baby
he got the idea for khan academy four
years ago when he taught a young cousin
how to convert kilograms to grams
many american students have trouble with
math and studies show they lag behind
their counterparts in asia and europe in
both math and science with khan's help
his cousin got good at math and he
eventually had a new career tapping into
anxieties around the world
now he records his lessons from a
converted closet in the back of his
bedroom he never goes on camera
kind of feels like the voice in their
head you're looking at it it kind of
feels like someone's over your shoulder
talking in your ear as opposed to
someone at a blackboard that's distant
from you although he is not the first
person to teach on the internet his
simple operation has attracted more
eyeballs than most university sites
for khan teaching math and science and
finance is just the beginning he's ready
to expand his youtube site to include
whatever strikes his fancy i want to do
everything i want to do history i want
to do grammar i want to do literally
every every subject
so far except for a little advertising
revenue he is donating his time and
equipment it's a one-man operation but
it's gotten so big he expects to start
soliciting outside support to keep his
academy growing
these are